J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK.
So we've been talking about
alkenes and their
polymerization.
Now, we will go on to the
triple-bond analogs, the
acetylenes, for just a little
bit, and then on to conjugated
systems, starting with allylic
intermediates, and then
dienes, and then, in general,
about linear and cyclic
conjugation and aromaticity.
So, we can generalize from what
we know about alkenes to
acetylenes--that we have the
same kinds of reactions,
additions of HBr, additions the
water, addition of H2.
But all these have a little bit
of a different twist. HBr,
we already mentioned this but
I'll go over it again,
stepwise addition, but
Markovnikov. The addition of
water, we see the possibility of
keto-enol tautomersim and
regioselection, as in alkenes.
And then in H2, there's a
question
of a stepwise addition--
one double bond and then the
other-- one multiple bond and
then the other--
and the question of
stereoselection.
Finally, some stuff about
acidity and based- catalyzed
isomerization of acetylenes
which you'll see are much more
acidic than alkenes are.
First, we talked about this
already but just to go over
it quickly once again, it's
possible to add HBr to a
triple bond like 1-hexene, and
you can use a catalyst that
helps makes the HBr more acidic,
and you can get a
single addition to give a
hexene--
2-bromo-1-hexene--
and you often use an inhibitor
so you don't get free-radical
addition of HBr.
Now we mentioned before it was
100 to 1000 times slower
than the comparable ionic
addition to the alkene, and the
reason is the vinyl cation is
not so great an intermediate.
And you can see that already in
gas-phase
ionization of the chlorides.
The one that gives the ethyl
cation requires only 193
kilocalories per mole to ionize
the chloride.
But the vinyl compound, to make
the vinyl cation,
requires another 32 kilocalories
per mole.
It's hard to make the vinyl
cation.
So that is, of course, what you
make when you add the
proton to the hexyne.
It's possible to isolate that in
40% yield which seems
funny, as we mentioned before,
because if it's not very
reactive, wouldn't the hexene
you make be even more reactive,
so that it would be impossible
to isolate something that was
part way along.
So, you can go further to
2,2-dibromohexane.
Obviously it's slower, and it
gives a second Markovnikov
addition, which if the bromo
substituent slows the addition
to an alkene, in order to make
it slower than the initial
addition to the already slow
alkyne, why is the orientation
Markovnikov?
And we saw the resolution to
that riddle a few lectures ago,
that the halogens do two things,
they withdraw
electrons through the sigma bond
and, therefore, make it
harder to form the cation.
But if you form the cation make
it next to the halogen so
at least you can profit from
stabilizing the unshared pair
on the halogen.
OK, we saw that before.
Now, hydration and hydrogenation
of alkynes.
First hydration, we can do the
same kind of thing we did
before, the alkoxymercuration,
which you
might remember forms an
unsymmetrical bridged ion,
then water can open it up, and
you get the addition of
mercury and OH,
hydroxymercuration.
Now remember what we did before
when this was an alkene
to begin with, and we had a
single bond in the product?
Nobody wants the mercury
compound.
Why did people make it?
The next step was reduction,
remove the mercury, and
replace it with H, so that what
you added
was effectively water.
Right?
So, they used sodium borohydride
to do that.
However, it doesn't wait around
for you to do that
under these conditions, because
you have acid there.
And with the double bond it's
possible for the
acid to add to it.
Now.
so you get that cation.
What's good about that cation?
Why is that easier to form than
it would have been if it
had just been a regular alkene?
Elisa?
STUDENT: There's the O there.
PROFESSOR: What does the O have
to do with it?
STUDENT: It's able to protonate
it and form the double bond.
PROFESSOR: No.
Well, a double bond gets formed
ultimately.
But, what's good about the
cation when you have the
oxygen next door?
Brandon, what do you say?
STUDENT: The p-orbitals?
PROFESSOR: Yes, it has unshared
electrons in the p
-orbitals, that could be
stabilize by the vacant p
-orbital next door.
So there's a resonance structure
that makes it
unusually stable.
A HOMO-LUMO interaction.
But, what leaves then is the
mercury plus.
So, you get this compound, which
is an enol.
Notice that it was formed with
Markovnikov orientation, as it
would have been the case if it
had started with an alkene.
But enols can undergo this same
acid-catalyzed reaction
to get that cation which is
stable as we can see in that
resonance structure,
And what could that do?
Lose a proton.
So it gives a ketone.
This got traditionally the name
keto-enol tautomerism.
"Tauto" means equivalent to,
right?
So the idea was that the ketone
and enol interconverted
so easily that it was impossible
to
isolate one or the other.
So that's a really easy allylic
rearrangement from one
end of from one allylic position
to the other.
And we talked about the
keto-enol equilibrium last
semester when we were talking
about bond strengths.
Just to remind you this is where
we went through it,
added up the bonds, and showed
that the ketone is much more
stable than that enol.
I'll just flip through that so
when you're reviewing it you
can look at it there.
So it goes to the ketone.
So the product from hydration of
an alkyne is a ketone.
The alkoxymercuration of an
alkyne-- it doesn't wait
around to do the sodium
borohydride reduction.
Now, remember, you could do the
other thing in an alkene,
add in the other
regiochemistry by using a
borane.
For acetylenes, you use a
special borane.
You get a vinyl borane as the
product, and it won't add a
second time if you have those R'
groups sufficiently
hindered, so that it blocks
access.
A way you can do that is with a
compound called
disiamylborane, which is made
with BH3 and that alkene. And
so you might think about what
the R groups are,
the R' groups, that you put on
there to make that hindered
one with a single H that then
adds only once.
So you got that vinyl borane and
do you remember what you
did with boranes when we added
to a double bond?
What was the next thing?
Hydroboration and then what?
Incidentally, this reminds me
that a week from today we have
another exam.
It'll cover today's and
Wednesday's lectures.
I'll give a review session
Wednesday evening.
I'll tell you, it will probably
be 8:00 to 10:00.
So, you have a week to learn
this stuff.
That's good news.
Anyhow, it was hydroboration and
oxidation
was the next thing.
Remember you treat it with
hydrogen peroxide and alkoxide
to make the borane into an
alcohol.
Right?
And then, in this case, we have
an enol as above.
So, that'll isomerize to a
carbonyl compound.
But notice it was
anti-Markovnikov. The addition
above was Markovnikov: the
oxygen went to the more
substituted center.
This one, the trick you use when
you do borane the O goes
to the less substituted center.
So in that case, you get an
aldehyde.
So, the H2 on one carbon and the
O on the other, add in one
sense here and in the opposite
sense here.
So that's nice because if you're
a synthetic chemist
that gives you the control of
which product you want to get.
You can use one method to get
the Markovnikov ketone and the
other to get the
anti-Markovnikov aldehyde.
So this is hydration with either
regiospecificity.
But, also, we could talk about
hydrogenation, adding H2, and
here it's a question of
stereospecificity.
Up at the top there, if we take
an alkyne and reduce it
with H2 and a catalyst, as we
talked about with an alkene,
you can get first this alkene.
You use a special catalyst, this
was developed by a guy
named Lindlar and he added lead
to the palladium
catalyst. Lead is a poison for
catalysts.
It makes the catalyst less
active.
Why might you want the catalyst
not to be very active?
Chris?
STUDENT: So it doesn't go all
the way.
PROFESSOR: So it doesn't go all
It'll do the acetylene, but it
won't do the alkene.
So you can stop and get it
there.
If you use a more reactive
catalyst, you
can go all the way.
So that deactivates the
palladium and stops at the
alkene stage.
And notice the two hydrogens
came in from the same side.
So it's a syn addition.
For example, you get a 97% of
that syn addition if the R is
this (CH2) esther group.
Now, on the other hand, if you
use sodium and ammonia, a
thing called a dissolving-metal
reduction, you get the
opposite stereospecificity.
It's an anti addition.
Now you might wonder--
the syn addition we talked about
before, the same thing
in an alkene about how the
palladium comes in and attacks,
then it gets replaced by one
hydrogen, by another hydrogen,
always front-side attack, so
that it comes out to be syn.
That one won't surprise you.
But why does this one give anti?
The key is that it's a
dissolving-metal reduction.
Incidentally, in that case, with
n-propyl groups it's an
80% to 90% yield of that anti
addition and I
think none of the syn.
So it's a dissolving- metal
reduction.
So sodium actually dissolves in
ammonia to give
electrons and Na+.
So it's a very interesting ion
pair.
It is an electron and a sodium
ion.
Of course, the electron is
solvated by ammonias is around
and about it, and it looks blue,
the
solutions of electrons.
Now if you're have a acetylene
an electron will add to it.
What orbital will it go into?
What's the LUMO all going to be?
Yigit, what do you say?
STUDENT: The CC pi-star?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, pi-star.
So notice it puts in--
there is already a pair of
electrons in that
corresponding pi orbital.
So now you have three electrons
among those two p-orbitals.
So, you can write it as one
being an anion with two
electrons, and the other being a
radical
was the third electron.
So, we have an anion radical as
an intermediate.
That, of course, is a very
strong base the carbon anion.
So it can react with the ammonia
and pull off a proton.
So, we've added an electron and
a proton. That's the
equivalent of adding a hydrogen
atom, although, it's
done is two stages.
So, we get this vinyl radical,
which is bent.
They're sp2 hybridized at that
functional carbon.
But they invert easily in the
case of a radical.
So it goes back and forth
between the R being on the
same side and the opposite side.
Now which one do you think is
favored.
Obviously, the one with the R
groups on the opposite side.
So with equilibrium that's the
one you have.
And now a second electron comes
along and goes into that
singly-occupied orbital.
So now you're going to have a
pair of electrons there.
We will write the minus charge
in that "sp
squared hybridized orbital.
But, now it's harder to invert.
Remember XH3, how if you added
more electrons it ceased to be
planar and became pyramidal.
The same idea here.
So now it doesn't flip back and
forth rapidly.
So, a second proton can be taken
away from the ammonia,
and we get that product, and the
two H's as
are on opposite sides.
It's an anti addition.
Why anti?
It's because that isomerization
of the radicals
favored the one with the R's far
apart from one another.
Then it got trapped as the anion
in that geometry.
And then it went on to give the
anti product, as we
gave yields of on the previous
slide.
Now, the final special thing
about alkynes that we're going
to talk about is there acidity
and how that relates to
isomerization of alkynes.
So, we looked before at these
pKa values for carbon,
nitrogen, and oxygen.
In the order you would expect
them to be.
But, then if you have an "sp
squared hybridized carbon or
an "sp hybridized carbon, they
get much more acidic.
We talked about this before.
And in some cases if you have
next door...if you're breaking a
CH bond and next door
and there's a double bond, you
can get extra acidity.
OK, that stabilization.
So anyhow, we've looked at those
pKas and here we can see
the energies of these three
isomers of an alkyne.
So, you have the alkyne on the
left, the lowest energy is
heavily substituted, on the far
right is one that's at the
end of the chain, so not having
as many carbon-carbon
bonds with the special sp
hybrid,
it's not a stable.
And in the middle we have the
diene version, the 1,2-diene.
So at equilibrium you would
strongly favor
the internal acetylene.
But how do you establish an
equilibrium among these?
You have to move hydrogens
around.
So at equilibrium, given those
energies, there's one 0.1% of
the 1,2-diene and 0.03% of the
terminal acetylenes.
So very little of those.
So, we just talked about the
fact that the terminal
acetylene could be rather
the internal acetylene could be
acidic because of the
pi bonds next door making the
anion more stable.
So, indeed you could do that, or
you could do this one,
that was on the previous slide
as well.
Or you could do the terminal
acetylene, which is the easiest
one to take off to put the
electrons in the low-energy
sp hybrid orbital.
Now the "pKa over here is 38.
So that means that the "Ka is
10^-38 or the energy involved
in getting up there's about 51
kilocalories per mole.
Over on the right it's 33
Still way up hill.
So those energies are quite far
above the... that's what we
know from the pKa's.
So if we wanted to take off a
proton, then put it back on,
and take off a different one,
put it back on and finally go
to the final anion, we would
have to go way up in energy.
If you have to go up 51
kilocalories per mole that's
not a very fast process.
The rate constant for that would
be 10^13 per second
times 10^-38 or the halftime
would be about 10^17 years
which is about 10^4 times the
time that's elapsed
since the big bang.
So don't wait around for that
one to happen.
Ok? So, obviously, you're not
going to be able to isomerize
that way by just let it ionize
off a proton.
But, if you put hydroxide in it
reacts with the proton to
make water and that's worth 21
kilocalories per mole.
Remember, the pKa is 16, 4/3 of
16 is 21.
So, 21 kilocalories per mole.
That makes it 21 kilocalories
easier to make the anion,
because you're not making
proton, you're making water.
So that's going to lower these.
Is that going to do the trick to
be able to isomerize?
Well, now the halftime would be
about 30 years at room
temperature.
But, if you warmed it to 150K it
would be about two minutes.
So, if you heat it up you could
make the
isomerization occur.
Then no matter which of these
you start with it's going to
equilibrate, and this is the
lowest energy form, and that's
going to be everything, except
there's going to be 0.1 % here
and 0.03% there.
So no matter which of these you
start with you're
going to get that.
However, suppose you use a
really strong base like amide.
So now that favors loss of a
proton.
That is it'll take the proton by
45 kilocalories per mole.
So now we're going to lower the
those ions even
further, like that.
And notice what happens on the
far right.
It goes all the way down there.
That's now the lowest energy
form, if you have NH2-.
So, instead of having it be all
here, which is what you're
going to have in any equilibrium
among the neutral
forms, this is going to be the
lowest-energy form.
So everything will be over
there, 7.2 kilocalories down,
which means that at equilibrium
you will have only
0.001% of this stuff, which was
always the
favored stuff before.
So everything is now over here.
So the trick is now you
neutralize it very rapidly.
So the trick to obtain a
terminal acetylene, remember
that anion is the one that has
the anion on the last carbon,
that's why it's such a stable
anion because it's sp
hybridized.
So, you a equlibrate with an
amide base in an amine solvent
to form the terminal anion.
Then you quench it by adding
water to donate a proton to
the terminal anion and also to
the RNH.
So you have only hydroxide now,
which is too weak to
allow equilibration.
Or if you want to, you could
just add acid so that you
don't even have OH there,
although,
that's gilding the lily.
You've already made it by not
having that
really strong base.
So you stopped equilibrium, you
put the proton on the
terminal acetylene, so you can
go from the internal, the more
stable one usually, to the
terminal
acetylene using the trick.
So that's all I wanted to say
about acetylenes.
Now we're going on for these
next two lectures, and a
little bit probably still beyond
the exam, to talk about
conjugation and aromaticity.
So conjugated pi systems is what
you're talking about.
The name conjugated comes from
an interesting root.
Conjugated systems are when you
have pi bonds separated by
a single bond.
They are called conjugated
because
they are yoked together.
The word yoke is the same root.
Yoke comes from jungere from
jugom which is to join.
So they're joined together.
They don't act independently.
And we talked about this already
in the first exam when
you memorized functional groups.
And on the exam I had a thing
that had both the carbonyl and
an amine, and they were near one
another.
But it's not a carbonyl group
and an amine group.
It's an amide group.
They are conjugated and they
behave in
their own special way.
So now we're going to talk about
conjugation.
So, conjugation is where the
localized orbital picture,
which remember we've talked so
much about pairwise two atoms
coming together to give a bond
and an anti-bond or isolated
the atomic orbitals.
That was our intermediate
between hydrogen-like atomic
orbitals, which we really
understood--
we had a table that we could
drawn them out-- and the
computer MOs, which looked very
complicated.
But in between were these
pairwise things.
But sometimes we have to think
more deeply when these things
are conjugated.
They don't behave that way.
So when does conjugation make a
difference?
First we're going to look at
experimental evidence, and
then we're going to go into the
theory.
So a classic example is allylic
stabilization.
Allyl comes from the word-- the
same as aioli--
or [? el ?] in French meeting
garlic.
There's a sulfide in garlic that
has a double
bond, that is carbon
double bond, single bond, and
then a
functional group, a sulfide.
So that's an allylic sulfide--
came from garlic.
So, allyl is these three carbons
in a row, double bond,
single bond.
So, you can get special
stabilization when you have
functional groups involved--
when you have rather
intermediates involved there,
like the cation intermediate.
So the energy for pulling off a
chloride for primary and
secondary are these values in
the gas phase.
Of course, very hard to separate
the ions, but if it's
allylic it's as good as being
secondary.
So allylic is very good.
Or if you look at anions. Look
at the "pKa of the OH.
Here it is 16 we know, if you
have a double bond here it
falls by six orders of
magnitude.
And in the case where it's an
oxygen here it falls by
another five orders of
magnitude.
You actually call it an acid.
So the anions get much more
stable when they're allylic by
about 8 kilocalories per mole,
in the case of the enol.
Or free radicals.
If you look at the bond
dissociation energy of a
normal CH bond, 101, but if you
make a double bond next door
so that this is allylic it's 89.
It is stabilized by about 13
kilocalories per mole.
So there's stabilization of
these reactive intermediates
when there allylic.
Now let's look at some more
detail about some of these
like the cation intermediate.
The addition of HX to butadiene.
We talked about HX, halogen
acids adding to
single double bonds.
How about adding into two double
bonds.
So at -78 degrees, you can add
HBr to butadiene, and you
could imagine the H+ going on
one of the internal carbons to
generate that cation or it could
go on the terminal
carbon, the other
regiochemistry, and generate
that cation.
Which of those do you think is
more likely to get?
Which one would you prefer, if
you were the proton?
Ayesha?
STUDENT: The one that's down.
PROFESSOR: The lower one.
Why?
STUDENT: It's a secondary
cation.
PROFESSOR: First, it is
secondary.
And it's also allylic
right, which the first one
isn't, because from this carbon
to the double bond there's an
intervening saturated carbon.
It's not two double bonds or two
sets of p orbitals
separated by a single bond.
There's no overlap between this
p
orbital and that "p orbital.
So, the second one is, of
course, also that, because
those are resonance structures.
But as Ayesha tells us, the top
one doesn't look so good.
So we're going to get one of
those.
But then in a second step we add
bromide.
If we do that at -78 degrees, of
course, we generated the
bromide when we attacked the
proton.
So, we could imagine getting
those two forms by attacking
this intermediate, which is
denoted by two resonance
structures.
Now, in fact, you get those in
the ratio of 80% to 20%.
Does that surprise you?
What would you expect for the
ratio of these two?
Here you have a terminal double
bond.
Here you have an internal bond.
Which one is more stable?
Do you like to have double bonds
more substituted or less
substituted?
Arvind, do you remember?
STUDENT: More substituted.
PROFESSOR: More substituted.
So, this is backwards.
It's 4 to 1 in the wrong
direction.
Now that means if you allow it
to equilibrate, it'll go the
way Arvind wants it to.
But, the initial product formed
at really low
temperature, at dry ice
temperature, is backwards.
You can cause--
this in fact, can ionize to go
back to the cation and then
come back, and that's a route
for equilibration
between these two.
And you can encourage the
bromide to come off by putting
ferric bromide in, if you want
to, it'll go faster.
But, at any rate, that's the
equilibrium.
So this is called kinetic versus
thermodynamic control.
So thermodynamic is equilibrium.
But kinetic is what you get
first, and those aren't
necessarily the same.
It's this case we've seen before
where you start and you
go up, a certain rate, and then
down to a product, or you could
go to a more stable product.
Hammond would say, you'd go
faster to the more stable
product, but sometimes,
remember, it crosses and it's
easier to get to the less stable
product, and that's
the example here.
It's a kinetic control under
that low temperature.
Now why when it's a question of
rate, the first one to be
formed, why do you think you
form the top one?
Anybody got a theory?
Yes.
STUDENT: The positive charge.
PROFESSOR: What about the
positive charge?
STUDENT: The electrons on the
bromine, the bromide ion, are
attached to the partner.
PROFESSOR: Right.
It looks like this is a
secondary versus primary:
more of this,
so that's where it attacks.
That looks like a good
explanation.
And that's what you'll see in
almost all textbooks.
So very good, Anurag.
You can write a textbook.
Let's look at the orbitals that
are involved in this just
for fun, quickly.
So here's a top view down on the
"four p
orbitals to the butadiene,
and here's the side view.
So here's the HOMO - 1.
That's the favorable combination
of
those "four p orbitals.
And here's the HOMO, that's the
unfavorable combination.
It's pi on this side, pi on this
side, but unfavorable
between them.
That's the HOMO.
The LUMO has two nodes among the
four p orbitals.
And what do you think the LUMO +
1 looks like?
It's got three nodes.
So you've got no nodes, one
node, two nodes, three nodes for
combinations among those p
orbitals.
Now , the HOMO is the one you
want to
attack with the proton.
So where should you attack it?
Probably, you get the best
overlap around in there.
Or you could look at how the
potential on the surface that
we talked about to see where the
best place for a proton is
and it's in the orange region.
So that seems to more or less to
agree.
It's about there.
So that's where the proton
should attack at
the terminal carbon.
And then it would give the
propenyl cation.
which is shown here.
There are three hydrogen on this
carbon here.
So that's the best product then.
Now that's the HOMO - 4, it's a
little bit silly to look at
that, but it's actually a CH
bond that is hyperconjugated a
little bit with the "p.
Now we have three "p orbitals
here, here, here.
The one that was here became
part of this CH bond.
Now, how about the rest of them?
Here's the home it's pi, here's
the LUMO one node, and
here's the LUMO + 1, two nodes
among those three "p orbitals.
So that's the propenyl cation.
There's the LUMO that you're
going to want to attack, if
you're the bromide.
So you could attack at either
end, not in the middle.
And if you look at the surface
potential, the worst place for
a proton is where it's very blue
here.
So that would be the best place
for bromide to come.
But it's in the plane of the
ring.
It's not a place you can form a
bond.
If you want to come in from the
top where you can form a
new bond, it's a little bit
green in there, and a little
bit blue, even, better there.
So the blue place +144 would be
the best place to attack, if
you want to form a bond.
That's where bromide would tend
to be in order to attack.
So one would think that this is
exactly what Anurag
proposed, that it should attack
there.
But here's a really interesting
paper that was
published in 1979, where what's
being added to is not
butadiene, but pentadiene,
another
methyl group, on there.
So they add DCl which adds to
the end to get the, as one
would expect, more substituted
allylic cation.
But now there's something
interesting about that.
That's symmetrical, except for
the fact that there's a
deuterium there.
So if a bromide now comes in, or
in this case they use
cholride, it could attack either
here or here.
If it attacks here, you get the
1,2-addition, D and Cl.
If it attacks here, you get
1,4-addition 4, D and Cl.
Now, if it had to do with the
kind of thing we talked about
before, where's the best place
to put a chloride, where do
you got the best overlap, and so
on.
That's the same here and here.
So it should be 50/50, in this
case because of the
intermediate being symmetrical.
when it was butadiene, and we
didn't have this methyl group
and it was unsymmetrical when we
did the analysis of the
previous slide, where would be
the best place to attack.
But now it's symmetrical, so we
should get 50/50.
So here's the product
distribution done in a bunch
of different solvents and
different temperatures and
just look at a couple of these.
If you do it at room
temperature, at 25 degrees you
get half again as much of this
as you do in this.
More chlorides adds here than
here.
And if you do it at low
temperature, you get three
times as much addition here as
here, even though it's
symmetrical .
So we've got to find some other
reason why when we do
this, the chloride tends to
attack here, rather than here.
1,2-addition rather than
1,4-addition.
Can anybody guess a reason for
that?
Well let's look at the
mechanism.
The first thing that happens is
we put a proton on and
generate this cation and also
choloride.
Now, do you have an idea?
Ayesha?
STUDENT: It's closer.
PROFESSOR: It's closer.
It has to move farther to get to
1,4 because this backside
attack on the hydrogen meant
that the chloride has to be
out here someplace--
closer to this end than to this
end.
So it appears that rapid
collapse of this ion pair that
you've made, before the ions
could move independently and
establish true symmetry that
competes, so that the collapse
competes with the motion that
would make it truly symmetric.
So it looks like it might not
have anything to do with where
the charge is on the surface or
which resonance
structure is better.
It's just where the chloride got
formed and that attacks
really quickly when the ion pair
collapses.
So you at it you could have
written a textbook, but you
might not have been right.
Now, allylic transition states
also are unusually stable, and
we actually mentioned this
before.
But if you look at an SN1
reaction so your breaking away
to get a cation,
the relative rates are, if you
take 100 for t-butyl which is
very easy to form the t-butyl
cation, the secondary is 10^4
times slower, and the primary
just doesn't happen.
It's way slower than that.
But if it's allylic then it's 5
times faster than secondary,
even though you might think it
would be primary.
And if it's allylic with a
methyl group on it, to make the
cation more stable that you're
forming when
you break off chloride,
it's half as fast as a
tertiary--
t-butyl choloride.
If you put two methyl groups
there, it's very much faster,
63 times faster than t-butyl.
And if you put a methyl group
here, however, on this carbon...
So we put a methyl group here it
accelerates enormously.
If we put two methyl groups
there it really accelerates.
[brief confusion]
If we put it on the other end
it's just as good.
But, this is what I wanted to
tell you, if you put the methyl
group in the middle it doesn't
help at all.
So the methyl group has to be on
one end or the other of the
cation you're going to make when
you lose the chloride,
in order to get that
acceleration.
If you put in the middle, it
doesn't help.
So again, we could look at where
the charge is in the
cation, and you have to put the
methyl, to
be effective in accelerating the
SN1 reaction--
it has to be where the charge is
going to be.
Now, how about SN2?
If we take the rate of ethyl
chloride to be 1 reacting with
ethoxide it's 37 times faster if
it's allylic.
And 97 times faster if you put a
methyl on,
and 560 times faster if you put
two methyls on.
If you put the methyl in the
middle it doesn't help
compared to not having a methyl.
But if you put the methyl at
this end, remember before when
we were doing SN1 forming the
cation, we could put it either
at this end or this end and got
the same rate,
now it's slower here.
Any idea why it should be slower
in this
case for the SN2?
How about the rate of t-butyl
for SN2?
You have t-butyl, three methyls,
and
you want to do SN2.
It's very hindered.
So this hinders the approach
because, remember you're
making a pentavalent carbon in
the transition state.
So allylic helps, but this time
you're going to get help
from the methyl at this end, but
not at this end.
So we looked at the allylic
cation, we looked at the
transition states involved in
forming the cation and in the
SN2 process.
Now let's look at the allylic
anion.
That's easily done by looking at
the acidity.
So we have a pKa of something
like 52, it's hard to measure
for that, but if you have it
allylic it's 43.
And that's helped by 9 powers of
10 or about 11
kilocalories per mole of
stabilization for losing that
proton at equilibrium.
And if you a phenyl ring there,
it what's called
benzylic, and now it's even more
so, about 16
kilocalories per mole.
So again having these pi things
where they can overlap
with the anion that's being
formed is very favorable-- the
order of 10 or 15 kilocalories
per mole.
How about free radicals?
Well here's a very
interesting...
these figures came out of this
paper by Ziegler where this
Ziegler is not the Ziegler who
teaches Chem 220.
This is the one who invented
Ziegler-Natta polymerization
and became quite wealthy.
So in 1942 working in Germany in
the Second World War he
was studying this process.
He could get a 58% yield of
substitution.
This bromination is a
substitution-- pulling off one
of these hydrogens and replacing
it by bromide.
Now for this purpose, the paper
that describes this,
describes this particular
compound which is called
N-bromosuccinimide.
And in ether solvent in 30
minutes using light--
What is the fact that he was
using light suggest?
That it might be a free-radical
chain reaction.
He was able to get this 58%
yield.
Now where does he get the
N-bromosuccinimide?
So that compound is succinimide.
He reacted it with base to make
the anion.
Does it surprise you that that
anion can
be formed with hydroxide?
Remember, NH has a "pKa of 30 or
something like that.
And hydroxide is only 16, the
"pKa of water.
How's it able to pull off that
protron?
What's good about that anion
that we formed?
Megan, do you have any idea.
STUDENT: The lone pair is
stabilized
by the pi-star orbitals.
PROFESSOR: Right.
You have two carbonyl pi-stars
to stabilize the high-energy
electrons on this nitrogen.
So you can make that anion, but
the pKa, incidentially, of
that is 9.5.
It's a very strong acid as NH
bonds go.
And that could do an SN2
reaction on Br2 to put bromine
on the nitrogen, and make the
bromide and anion together
with the sodium ion that came
from hydroxide.
So that's how he got NBS.
But you can take it apart again,
if instead of
using base, use acid.
So if you use HBr, you could
protonate this.
You could protonate that oxygen
and you could draw a
resonance structure here like
that.
So it's easy to protonate here.
But now you can take the bromide
and do an SN2
reaction on the Br.
So you generate this, now
neutral, which is an enol that
easily isomerizes back to the
starting material.
So in base you could make this
with bromine, and if you add
HBr, you come back.
And of course get Br2 that was
what was formed here.
So you can get the Br2 back
again, if you want to, from NBS.
Now back to the reaction.
We can imagine doing a reaction
of Br2
with a double bond.
What reaction have we talked
about, Br2 plus a double bond?
It's the addition, electrophilic
addition to a double bond.
We talked about this a good
deal.
No doubt it will be covered on
the exam next Monday.
You do this at room temperature
in the dark.
You get the bromonium ion first.
Remember, how we talked
about that and then you get anti
addition.
Now, but suppose you want to do
substitution.
That's what Ziegler did.
He didn't add bromine to the
double bond, he replaced an
allylic hydrogen with bromine.
So those substitutions are
typically free-radicals
substitutions.
So you could have this same
compound, but I show the
hydrogens, because if you have
ways to get a free radical,
like a bromine atom, it can pull
off, get HBr, add this--
but remember, we use bromine in
here, not chlorine, because
it's slow and selective.
So if you use chlorine, it takes
not only this hydrogen
but also this hydrogen almost as
rapidly:
it's not selective. But bromine
is selective:
it's uphill.
Then you could react it with Br2
and replace where the
hydrogen is with bromine.
So you've done allylic
bromination.
And, of course, this allylic
intermediate was
resonant in this form.
You could have put the bromine
either here or here.
So you also get that, which is
the same material in the case
shown, but if you had a
substituent, it would be in a
different position.
If you had something on the ring
substituted here it would
be a different compound.
And it also gives a bromine
atom.
Why is that relevant?
What happens to the bromine
atom?
Matt?
STUDENT: It gets reused in the
free-radical chain.
PROFESSOR: Right, it goes back
to the start.
It is a chain reaction.
So how do you control which
you're going to get?
Are you going to get bromine
addition or allylic
substitution?
Can you think of any way of
controlling which of these.
You put bromine in, which of
these
things is going to operate?
Is there any handle you have on
it?
STUDENT: You can use
photoinitiation to get the
radical.
PROFESSOR: If you use-- noticed
this
was done in the dark.
If we can't get the radical, we
won't do this one.
So one idea is to keep it in the
dark.
Don't use the initiator.
So that'll allow us to do this
one, that dark one.
How do we get this one to
happen?
Well you might say we use light
or use an initiator.
But this can still happen if you
have the light on.
You can still get that.
It doesn't require dark.
It's just this one requires
light.
So this one would also be going
on, but there's another
way which is to minimize the
concentration of Br2.
Now, why does that have anything
to do with it?
This is a really interesting
thing about the kinetics of
the top reaction.
It's second order in Br2.
That looks really weird.
Why do you need two molecules of
bromine
in order to do this?
The reason is that when you get
the Br plus coming on Br minus
is coming off from Br2.
So you have to get Br minus.
And, in fact, Br minus is
stabilized by reacting with
Br2 to give Br3 minus.
So, in fact, what happens is
that the Br, the second Br2
helps the bromide leave from Br
plus in a non-polar
solvent like this.
So it's second order, So that
means if you have a really low
concentration of Br2, this one
gets really slow, because it's
a bad leaving group.
It's like making the Br minus
leave by putting Br2 in is
like making OH leave by putting
a proton on it. Make it a
better leaving group.
So if we minimize the
concentration of Br2 we'll slow
this one down, but that reaction
with Br2 is very
fast. Remember, the first step
of this is endothermic, is
slow, but that's step is really
fast. So we can
tolerate a low concentration of
Br for this purpose, but
how are you going to do it.
Because suppose you put in just
a teeny
amount of Br2 there.
OK, this starts in, but quickly
you've exhausted the
Br2, and now the radical chain
stops,
and that's the end of the line.
Now you could say I'll very
carefully
run in Br2 very slowly.
Just to balance out.
But when you put a drop in the
bromine concentration is
higher in that drop, locally, so
you're going to get this
reaction, because of the local
high concentration of Br2.
But this is where Ziegler comes
in with
his clever NBS molecule.
This looks like it's tedious to
impossible to maintain a
really low concentration of Br2
while it's being consumed
all the time. But notice that
this reaction also yielded
HBr, whenever that happens.
And if we have
N-bromosuccinimide plus HBr
that's the reaction we looked
out on the previous slide that
destroys N-bromosuccinimide--
takes it back to succinimide.
And you remember what the other
product was?
Br2.
So isn't this neat?
Whenever a Br2 molecule gets
used up, a new Br2 molecule is
created by this reaction.
So it automatically maintains
the minimum possible
concentration of Br2. Every time
you use it,
you get a new one.
You don't have to sit there with
your burette, trying to run
it in very slowly.
So that's the trick with
N-bromosuccinimide.
Now, so we've looked here at a
lot of different allylic
stabilizations.
But dienes can also be
conjugated, and how much is
that worth?
We can look at the heat of
combustion of this one, where
they're not conjugated and this
one, where they are across
a single bond, these isomers of
one another.
And you can see that it's the
conjugation seems be worth
about 7 kilocalories per mole.
Or down here it seems to be
worth about 8
kilocalories per mole.
But these numbers, although,
they're claimed to be very
precise, are big numbers.
And I think that precision might
be a little bit
overstated.
If you look at the heat of
hydrogenation, the heat that
is given off when you add H2,
then you can see that these
are all 30.
I'm going to let you go after
you make two guesses.
Now guess what each--
this double bond, this double
bond, this double bond, they
all give off 30 kilocalories per
mole of heat.
How much should this one give
off?
When you hydrogenate both double
bonds.
Leen?
STUDENT: 60.
PROFESSOR: Right.
How about this one?
Natalie?
STUDENT: 60.
PROFESSOR: How about this one?
STUDENT: Something bigger. Much
more. 62.
Oh. Much less.
PROFESSOR: So conjugation.
This one is more stable.
It doesn't give off as much
heat.
And it seems to be stable by
about four
kilocalories per mole.
OK, now you can go.